Donald Trump hilariously said yesterday that
the difference between him and Nixon is that
Nixon left and Trump is not going to leave.
And this is hilarious because it implies that
the difference is not that Nixon did bad things
and Trump didn't.
It implies that the difference is not that
Nixon committed crime crimes and Donald Trump
didn't.
If you have some sense of Watergate, you probably
have realized by now that the current Trump
situation is actually worse than Watergate.
In many ways, Trump and Nixon both fired people
to try to stop investigations into them.
That's obstruction both Nixon and Trump dangled
pardons often through attorneys in front of
people in different ways and otherwise try
to influence witnesses to lie.
The Muller report, just like the Watergate
roadmap outlines the wrongdoing by Trump as
the other document did with Richard Nixon,
but there's a huge way in which Trump 2019
is worse than Nixon, 1974 which is that in
1974 republicans eventually came around and
realize that Nixon had to go 2019 Republican's
are way more partisan and a moral than Republicans
in 1974 and it makes the entire situation
far worse than 1974 because we have an entire
Party with a few exceptions, very few.
That's not going to hold Donald Trump accountable.
So then in comes Trump more and more talk
of impeachment, more and more demand for an
impeachment inquiry in the House of Representatives.
And yesterday, Trump decides it's time to
draw a line, draw a distinction between him
and Nixon in [inaudible] 74, who of course
resigned before Republicans and Democrats
could impeach him, which they were going to.
And Trump yesterday says, after repeating
the normal, no collusion, no obstruction,
stuff that the difference between him and
Nixon is that Nixon eventually left and Donald
Trump will not leave.
Does not leave.
Check it out.
You can't impeach somebody when there's never
been anything done wrong.
We have a no collusion.
We have no anything.
There's no obstruction.
There's no collusion.
There's no anything.
Uh, when you look at past and beach was, whether
it was President Clinton or I guess President
Nixon never got there.
He left.
I don't leave.
There's a big difference.
We did nothing wrong except create the greatest
economy of the history of our country.
Now I get it trumps not saying he did something
wrong.
He's, if anything, implying Nixon did nothing
wrong either, but left anyway because of pressure
and Trump having done nothing wrong as far
as he's concerned is not going to leave.
That being said, I agreed the main differences
between Nixon and Trump are that number one,
Nixon was much smarter and that Nixon eventually
left, whereas Trump's ego and narcissism will
probably prevent him from ever choosing to
leave, meaning it's going to be up to us to
remove him, which most efficiently will happen
17 months from now, less than 17 months from
now in November of 2020 when we had that election
and can vote them out because even though
Trump is insisting on no collusion, no obstruction,
there's this hint of truth in what Donald
Trump says.
Nixon got caught.
Nixon accepted responsibility.
I won't.
Donald Trump is saying now, there is one other
interpretation here.
Trump has this projection tendency where he
often blames the other for doing what he did
or he says the opposite of what he's actually
saying, thinking.
So lots of examples of Trump saying he has
full confidence in a particular staffers work
and then that staffer is fired a week later.
Many examples of that.
So the other interpretation here is that Trump
is in a sense projecting by even bringing
up the idea that Nixon left than I won't leave.
It's a signal that Trump is actually starting
to think about leaving.
I don't know.
And by the way, in July of 1973 Nixon also
said that he wasn't going to leave and the
New York Times check this out from a July
20th, 1973 a report.
President Nixon emerged from the hospital
today Pale but combative and immediately denounced
suggestions that he resigned as just plain
poppycock interpreting for the vocabulary
of the time.
This is what Donald Trump is saying today.
I'm not going to go.
Nixon of course eventually did and maybe Donald
Trump will as well.
It's another criminal talking about how he
would never resign until Nixon actually resigned.
If you're Trump and so far you've gotten away
with everything.
It does make sense to just say, I'm not leaving
period.
If and until something changes and that's
up to us the best path forward.
I've outlined it now for several weeks.
An impeachment inquiry should immediately
start in the house of Representatives.
The point of it is not to actually remove
Trump because it won't.
We're not going to get Republicans between
now and November of 2020 to remove Donald
Trump.
V Peach meant the point of the impeachment
inquiry is to damage Trump by exposing the
content of the Mueller report to turn voters
against Donald Trump so that they will ultimately
vote him out in November of 2020 period.
That is the best path forward.
If you disagree, let me know.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
Follow us
both and let me know what you think